you and Adele are real close huh I mean
like crazy clothes yeah we met when in
Cardiff years ago
on a show that was on channel 4 in
England called T4 transmission this is
like before even 19 that album 19 was a
huge hit this is so early
yeah we hit it off really well and then
my wife is good friends with some of her
childhood friends and that kind of
reconnected us but we'd keep bumping
into each other stay very close and then
you know we have we have uh photos in
like our first apartment in London Jules
and I of like Adele holding uh someone
who's like three weeks old like it's
it's a deep sort of family nice
connection it's and I just love her must
be a really freaky feeling when someone
you know you kind of knew and you know
you were hanging out with her she's your
friend and then all of a sudden that
album breaks big and the career is like
bigger than anyone couldn't have been
less shocked I couldn't have been less
you knew I oh my god well that's that's
how that's how I went up to it and I was
like I think she I I went up to her and
I was like
um because she has the cover of Make You
Feel My Love on that album
and it's as good a cover I think like
I'm always of the feeling that like how
can any cover version be better than the
original because it couldn't exist
without the original but I think there's
a couple that come real real close like
Amy Winehouse's Valerie
James Blake's a case of you and Adele's
Make You Feel My Love and it's
extraordinary and I just it's so clear
and what's amazing with her is there is
this there is this seismic gap between
the artist and her and spend enough time
with her personally you could forget
I I forget like
and then she'll just sing along to
something and you're like
oh my God
I mean I think she is a generational
talent I think and I couldn't be less
shot
foreign